in this lesson you're gonna learn how to
solve systems of linear equations in two
variables with two equations using
Cramer's rule so you've probably already
learned how to solve systems of
equations using the substitution method
the elimination method the graphing
method and other methods but in Kramer's
rule we're doing is we're using matrices
and specifically the determinant of a
matrix so let me show you how to work
through this with this example right
here 2x minus y equals 7x minus y equals
4a now an easy way to set this up is to
go like this x equals and y equals and
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the determinant of a matrix divided
by the determine of a matrix same thing
for y the determinant of a matrix
divided by the determinant of a matrix
and where we get these matrices from is
gonna be from the coefficients okay the
numbers in front of the variables here
so we've got two one negative one
negative one the same thing for the
denominator 2 one negative one negative
one same thing for the Y 2 1 negative 1
negative 1 2 1 negative 1 negative 1 now
when you're solving for x what you want
to do is you want to replace the
coefficients in front of X with the
solution so I'm going to do is I'm going
to erase the 2 and the 1 and replace it
with 7 and for what I'm solving for y I
want to replace the coefficients in
front of the Y with the solutions 7 and
for the denominator I did not change
I just left those as the coefficients in
front of the variables there for both x
and y so that's all we really did was we
just changed the coefficients for X the
coefficients for Y in the numerator now
you see these vertical bars that means
to tell us to take the determinant of
the matrix just to refresh her the
determinant of a matrix is going to be
this diagonal a times D minus this
diagonal e times C ok so that's a quick
way to do it so over here what we have
is 7 times negative 1 which is a
negative 7 minus negative 1 times 4
which is negative 4 of course when we
subtract that it's like adding the
opposite its negative 3 over here in the
denominator this diagonal negative 2
minus this diagonal negative 1 times 1
is negative 1 when we subtract it's like
adding the opposite that's
equal to negative one and so we have a
negative 3 divided by negative 1 which
is 3 so that's what x equals 4 why it's
going to be the exact same thing we take
this diagonal 8 minus this diagonal 7 so
that's 1 and then the denominators going
to be the same as the denominator here
well let's just do it again for practice
that's going to be negative 2 minus a
negative 1 which is equal to negative 1
and 1 divided by negative 1 is a
negative 1 so our solution is going to
be 3 comma negative 1 and that just
represents where these two lines would
cross or intersect if you want to see
another example follow me over to that
video right there and we'll do another
one